we found some really fun headlines um
where i was excited to hear from other
people in the news and the zeitgeist and
the world and what their valentine's day
relationships practices
outlooks uh were so you want to get into
it yep i'm ready i'm so excited okay
ready first up when we're in love we can
all go a little bananas and buzzfeed
just compiled a list of some of the
wildest things that celebs have ever
done for love oh this should be good i
know when rihanna won the mtv vanguard
award uh drake bought her a billboard to
congratulate her at the time yes very
nice
um this one i like justin bieber wanted
to treat selena gomez to dinner and a
screening of titanic so he rented out
the staples center i like that as one
does i like that
um and then who could forget when pamela
anderson and tommy lee got married to
each other after only four days that's
how much they wanted to show each other
that they were in love
after four days
i got a great love story magic johnson
we all love magic johnson and cookie and
his wife they've been married for 30
years for their 30th wedding anniversary
he rented out a ballroom at a hotel with
a table for two with a 12-course dinner
with her favorite band frankie uh
frankie beverly um and so they spent the
night just the two of them dancing in
the whole ballroom and eating i just
thought that was isn't that sweet i
thought that was so sweet so romantic as
a surprise for her all right gail your
story here's here's the next story if
you're planning to give your valentine
flowers you might need to how do they
say up your game a little bit a study
finds
that most disappointing valentine's
gifts are flowers
heart-shaped boxes of chocolates and
fuzzy handcuffs
so drew here's a question have you
gotten any of those cliche gifts or
given any of those cliche gifts
no not really um i've i've been very
inventive on valentine's day uh i feel
really actually good about my
valentine's day game do you care to
share um like one time i made um
i took an x-ray of my heart and put it
on a light board for my ex-boyfriend
fabi and he used to make me zoetrope
machines and we would like ekg and get
like we were very inventive so we had
the best valentine's day i like that
i've ever had in my mind well i think
that's nice
he was the best he is that's nice i once
had a the oprah show you guys remember
the oprah show back in the day
she had a guest on who said you should
wrap yourself in saran wrap
and then when your significant other
comes home you have on this you know
trench coat and you go tada so i wrapped
myself in saran wrap your buck naked you
put on the trench coat he comes he comes
up the steps i go tonight he goes what
are you doing
[Laughter]
that sort of kills the mood so i just
went nothing nothing
so that i haven't been adventurous since
i'm so late but i'm going to steal your
idea of x-raying my heart i like that
when i meet somebody i like that well i
might have to steal your surroundings
[Music]